what up yo
it is february 1st 2021
i am dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message
that's right it is the first day of the
second month
of the year of healing the year of unity
it's here
we got through january it was a bit of a
blur
had some strange things happen you know
capitol hill thing
president being completely decimated
from social media
lots of executive actions new
administration
california technically two days ago
reopened so you can sit outside at
something like 25 capacity and have a
cup of coffee with a friend it's all
very exciting
we are in month two and who knows
what'll happen in month two and if you
just want a little perspective as to
how the world sort of goes faster and
faster as time goes by
it was really in february of last year
that we first started
talking about kobe just a little bit
there was a tiny bit
of sort of insider info dropping in
january but there were presidential
uh debates on the democratic side
obviously where where nobody was talking
about it
then february we talked about a little
bit more than march is when it all
kicked in
uh anyway got a ton to catch up on with
you guys before i do anything though
you know that stephen crowder fella over
at blaze tv
uh he announced this morning that he is
suing
facebook apparently he's got some
insider info that facebook has been
messing
with the numbers he made the
announcement this morning so go to
blazetv.com
crowder and see what he's up to and you
know i've long said you know you have to
fight
big tech on many fronts you have to
fight them by building new products
that's what i'm doing with locals.com
you have to fight them
legally that's what crowder's doing you
have to fight them
sometimes with whatever governmental
power that you have that's what a lot of
people are calling for right now
although i think you got to be careful
what you wish for
and that you just sort of do it in a
holistic sense so you know you just if
you were invading another country if you
were fighting a war you'd have foot
soldiers you'd have a navy you have an
air
force the whole thing so everyone kind
of fights it differently uh oh
oh and real quick um make sure that you
are subscribed to our channel i keep
getting a ton of emails from people
that you say you're subscribed but you
never see the videos in the feed so
click
the little bell there just click that
bell and then you can
you know sort of select whether you want
to see all our videos or some of the
videos or whatever
blah blah blah blah blah oh one other
thing before we get to story number one
so as you guys know i was in dallas for
a couple days it was great to
to be with glenn and the blaze crew and
we shot a bunch of stuff and they have
just
an absolutely incredible uh set and
studio over there i did a i did a little
video that we posted
on my locals community uh behind the
scenes they have the largest sound stage
between
new york and los angeles in the entire
united states so it's a massive what
feels like almost like a massive
warehouse
with just tons of sets and they're
building constantly
uh and it's it's pretty awesome and
maybe they'll build me a little studio
there they're trying to get me out to
dallas although florida
keeps calling we shall see but the
reason i mention that is because
uh one of the things that i did uh in
the community was i posted okay guys in
a couple hours i'm gonna be at this
restaurant
and let's do a happy hour and about 40
real live people showed up yes that's
right i got to shake hands and there was
some hugging involved
people want to touch me they want to
touch there's always a touching they
want to touch
but it was incredible we we had drinks
with about 40 people a bunch of people
had dinner and just meeting all sorts of
different people from the community and
it was an interesting diverse
in the right sense of diverse crew of
people by the way one of the girls i
can't remember her name right now
but she was super pregnant was about to
pop i saw on the community this morning
that she had a baby this morning so
congratulations to girl whose name i
can't remember i'm sorry that i can't
remember your name but if we can figure
it out maybe we'll try to
get it i met a lot of people anyway it
was just great seriously it was just
great meeting actual people and just
being out and about
and all that good stuff all right let's
talk a little politics um
you know this joe biden fella he's our
78 year old president with cognitive
problems that we're not allowed to talk
about who
said a whole bunch of stuff during the
campaign and since he's been in office
has gone completely woke and i had been
warning all my good
liberal friends about this guys this is
exactly what was going to happen well
you may remember a couple moments during
the campaign
where biden was trying to show himself
as sort of the more centrist the more
moderate the guy going oh you know there
are some things that i'd like to do but
i can't do
all of them because i'm just the
president and as the head of the
executive branch i'm just supposed to
sign some things into law but i can't
write laws
that's not what the president's there to
do well that's what joe biden used to
say
let's take a look we are a democracy
some of my republican friends and some
of my democratic friends even
occasionally say
well if you can't get the votes by
executive order you're going to do
something
things you can't do by executive order
unless you're a dictator we're democracy
we need consensus lordy lordy joe
things that you can't do by executive
order
unless you're a dictator hmm well
we've got an image here this is the
amount of executive actions that were
signed by the previous guys oh you know
guys i don't have this in front of me
right now can we uh
can you just read off some numbers for
me because i can't quite see it we just
threw this image in at the last second
i think i'm gonna get handed a computer
and read this to you well you guys are
seeing it right in front of you well
here
as as we're showing that to you joe
biden in two weeks
i know this number off the top of my
head joe biden in two weeks has signed
42 executive actions now
you just saw that video there which is
just from a couple months ago where he's
talking about
how you know unless you're a dictator
you shouldn't be doing that okay now
i've got the numbers in front of me
um executive orders through october 13th
of past presidents trump had 49 obama 26
33 38 clinton h.w 27
reagan 42 and carter 47.
to be clear that's october 13th meaning
that they got installed as the president
on january 20th
and then october 13th is many months
later joe biden has done 42
in basically two weeks almost to the day
um
look this is the way we're sort of
governed now and it's it's a shame look
i believe
that the president should have
some leeway to sign these things right
our government is sort of
locked and and just sort of stuck and i
think in some ways there's probably
some goodness there like a government
that's kind of stuck that can't do too
much well it can't do too much good
stuff and it can't do too much bad stuff
now i don't think the government
as a general rule especially in the
times we live in i don't think the
government really functions to do a lot
of good stuff
so the fact that it can't do a lot of
good stuff and a lot of bad stuff sort
of works for me
and i'm okay with the president having
some leeway
to to sort of push the national dialogue
in a certain way but the idea and we've
discussed this many times that you know
you come in for four years you do
everything by executive action
you just reverse the executive actions
of the guy before you if you're not in
the same party
uh it's a very bipolar way of being
governed right
this is not how we're supposed to be
governed again civics 101 the
legislative branch right the congress
the senate the house of representatives
they're supposed to write the laws get
the laws passed the president then
signs them the judiciary make sure that
they're legal this is this is basic
stuff and i know i repeat myself
on some of this sometimes but i think
unfortunately most people don't
understand this i really think
at this point i'd love to see some
numbers on this maybe we can find it for
another show this week
just like what percentage of americans
understand
basic civics basic like separation of
powers
the different branches of government and
what they are supposed to do
there was also a really spectacular
moment
during the debates that you guys may
remember where kamala harris
who at one point was kind of thought of
as the front-runner it's hard to
remember this
but like the first two or three debates
she was really sort of hot people like
oh it's going to be her it's going to be
her
and she's got that cocky swagger and
that evil laugh and the whole thing
and there was a moment where she was
going after biden right because she had
to
take out bite and he was sort of the
more establishment guy and they were
asked a question
about executive actions on guns and joe
biden
said well no you can't do it because
it's the second amendment and you can't
do everything by executive action
and she looks at joe and she tackles
with that evil laugh and she's like joe
can't you say yes we can he
um and that really tells you the way she
thinks meaning oh
you can use executive actions to
supersede the constitution now
fortunately
the constitution does still exist at
least for now
and you can't do that but that shows you
sort of once biden steps down which
obviously will happen at some point
it shows you what kamala's sort of
thought process is related to all this
and that she would use
every bit of power that could she could
attain and by the way as when i say you
know as fortunately the constitution
still exists
it's only it only exists if it exists
in that we enforce it right otherwise
it's just the words written on paper
and in many ways we've allowed the
government to just kind of do whatever
they want all the time and i think it's
it's deeply dangerous anyway again if
this was a republican i'd be complaining
i didn't really like it when trump did
it
you can find old videos of me on tyt
when i was a lefty talking about how i
didn't like it when obama did it and you
got to be careful
what you asked for so if this is just
the way we're going to be governed and
have some sort of deadlock congress
then just every four years we'll have
one country every four years in another
country
every four years after that and
unfortunately you know this is where
it's like
i actually believe in biden in biden's
heart of hearts
especially if this was five years ago
and he was a little bit sharper or
if he was just advising if he was still
vice president right
so this is now six years ago let's say
and he was vice president and he was
advising
obama i actually believe that biden
would be talking about the constitution
and would be saying at times to obama
and i'm sure this happened
that obama wanted to do more with
executive actions and i'm going to guess
that biden actually stopped him from
doing it but as you guys know the point
is that biden's not really
in charge anymore so i suspect we will
we will see more and more of this
uh let's move on to uh this gamestop
situation so you all know about the
crazy game stop situation the hedge fund
managers we're going to short game stop
which gamestop obviously it's a brick
and mortar video game store obviously
not doing well and what the hedge fund
guys can do in effect is short the stock
so they can make money
as the company is destroyed well then
the wall street bet guys the the
redditors
the underbelly of the internet people
many of whom i know
are watching this show right now and
that are good
interesting just individuals trying to
have fun and make a little money and
play the game and all of that stuff as
all of us have been pushed out
and and only the elites seem to be
allowed to play the game
uh what they decided to do was start
buying a ton of gamestop stock
it then crushed the hedge fund managers
who were trying to short the stock
because then the stock rose in price and
they were trying to get it
really low and there's all sorts of hell
breaking loose and i think this is just
such a
fantastic story not only because it
involves video games and as you know i
was assistant manager of electronics
boutique in broadway mall in hicksville
long island in 1999
moved more red pokemon than anyone uh
not only that but i do love
i love games i don't really play much
anymore i play i have an arcade miss
pac-man in my garage that's pretty much
it at this point
and an nba jam in there um but it's also
like this is such a perfect story of
like the people
the people just coordinating to like get
in on the financial game stick it to the
man like
be allowed to trade on these apps freely
this robin hood app that was created so
that people could get in on this without
having money managers without having
giant hedge fund accounts without having
all of the tools that wealthy people
have by the way you know i don't
begrudge wealthy people any of these
tools
but then these apps like robin hood came
around and said hey you can get in on
this so then what happened these people
start coordinating
they start getting in on it sort of as a
joke i put 50 bucks in on on gamestop
i'm not sure what it's worth right now i
just did it to
kind of be fun but then in essence the
entire machine
crashes down on them robinhood the app
stops trading uh then you see all sorts
of like
crazy people on mainstream media talking
about how they're all white supremacists
and a whole bunch of other stuff
so first let's let's go to this video
this is jimmy kimmel
now i don't know who anyone who watches
these shows anymore is anyone out there
watching jimmy kimmel
is anyone else is anyone watching
stephen colbert like these
boring leftist corporatist losers like i
can't imagine anyone watching it i i
can't even really imagine anyone
watching bill maher anymore
that one like a little bit i suppose but
just like these giant machine
mouthpieces well listen to what uh jimmy
kimmel
said about the whole uh wall street bets
robin hood gamestop situation
gamestop if you don't know it's a video
game store and like a lot of businesses
they've been struggling because of
covert but also
because most people buy games online now
and yet despite a sharp decline in sales
over the past six months their stock
price has grown by eight
thousand percent because a bunch of
amateur investors
maybe even some russian disruptors who
are part of a reddit community
called wall street bets decided to buy a
bunch of gamestop stock
god you see the way he did that there so
he's telling you the story he kind of
got the first part right
amateur investors but he says it with a
certain disdain i mean you can
go back in a second and listen to what
he says a bunch of amateur investors
like they don't get to play the game
and russian disruptors yes
yes it was a bunch of russians have we
heard this story before
guys hold on a second
have we heard this story before the
russians are doing it yes
when when the people coordinate on
reddit
when the people decide to go against the
powers that be what happens
a corporate mouthpiece that's all jimmy
kimmel is
i'm sorry i met the guy once seemed nice
enough we shook hands at a wedding
okay this isn't even about him really
but like the way he gets up there like
who wrote that
who wrote that line like somebody they
coordinate somewhere the powers that be
like that's how these corporate shows
work do you understand that like a bunch
of
amateur investors and russian disruptors
like he didn't
he didn't put that line in there himself
but that's again this is what
the sort of blue pilling of america is
there's a reality that happens
right and you guys know what the reality
of the gamestop situation is i just laid
it out in pretty layman's terms right
you don't
i'm not i don't consider myself like
some sort of financial genius or
or a big uh money market manager
extraordinaire right like i'm giving you
the 101 on this stuff and you guys can
can google it all for yourself but in
essence you get it they were trying to
destroy this company
the the gamers got in started buying the
stocks they raised the price of it now
all these hedge fund managers start
losing a lot of money so the whole
system crashes down
it's like ah it's the russians but it's
not just
the russians because newsweek chimed in
and i think you're gonna understand
where i'm going
here quote far right activists and
conspiracy theorists on the telegram
messaging service
jumped on the chaos as validation of
their ideologies
and a potential recruiting event for
disaffected users
several tied the trading platform's
actions to anti-semitic conspiracy
conspiracy theories and blamed wealthy
jewish people
for the decision ah yes
again you see what they do here once
people
start standing up against the machine
suddenly you're
a white supremacist you're a neo-nazi
now do you think
do you think that we've been through
this game before now obviously there was
russia russia russia russia hillary
clinton claiming that tulsi gabbard
remember she was a russian asset
during the primaries and then of course
there was you know four years of
pretending that
russia was working with trump and got
elected by trump
we were allowed to do that for four
years now you can't say anything about
the thing that happened you know a
couple months back because i don't want
to get deleted off the youtube
um but do you see what they do
automatically you're called a white
supremacist and now the way they brought
telegram in on that like they're going
to try to take out
telegram the same way they took out
parlor but i was thinking you know for
for those of you that are somewhat new
in this space or if you're just sort of
trying to right now like catch up on
like what's happened
over the last couple years do you know
how many articles
that i was in me dave rubin i think you
guys
know my political beliefs i've got a
book back there defending
liberalism which is now a conservative
position by the way um
i think you know i'm not a radical i'm
well i'm a radical freedom extremist but
i'm not a
i'm not a political radical in that i
want anyone to be
uh you know the victim of bigotry of or
of racism or of sexism or homophobia or
any of those phobias if this phobia is
everywhere arachnophobia i'm okay with
if you have a healthy fear of spiders i
think that's good but the rest of it no
good
um do you know how many articles that i
was included in in the new york times in
vox in daily beast in huffpo
in mediate all of these craptastic
old legacy media things and they are
legacy media things even buzzfeed i
would say is a legacy media
operation at this point where i where
jordan peterson
where ben shapiro where we were called
alt-right and we were called
nazis and white supremacists and all of
these things
for those of you who have read my book i
come from a family that lost holocaust
member lost family in the holocaust on
both sides i grew up around holocaust
survivors but but that's a
that's a moot point you can still have
bad ideas
uh generations after something bad
happens to your own people
but i don't believe in any of those
things i believe in the individual
that's what i believe i should
i believe you should be treated on your
actions and your thoughts and nothing
else right
but over the years those of us that
defended free speech
those of us that defended open inquiry
those of us that said identity politics
is bad the new racism of identity
politics
we were called white supremacists we
were called neo-nazis
the new york times you may remember this
ran a front
page sunday cover story saying that
youtubers lead people to the alt right
with the huge
picture of me they actually put my
picture on page three giant picture
and the headline beneath it was like
youtube leading people to the alt-right
and my dad
goes to the bagel shop on sunday
mornings and had a friend come up with
him
come to him with the new york times and
say i didn't know david was a
guy i know from childhood i didn't know
david that's what he used to call me
david before i
transitioned to dave that i don't know
david was the head of the alt-right
this is the game that these people play
and they're doing such a duplicitous and
dangerous game by the way
this has nothing to do with white
supremacy this has nothing to do
with bigotry or racism or anything like
that but it's like all they have left
when when the people start saying
something that is true
the machine only knows how to crack down
on them and call them deplorable and
all of these horrible things and then
what do you do you further
push these people to the margins of
society so i guess i'm on the margin of
society with you guys
and i'd rather laugh with the sinners
than cry with the saints
and only the good die young somebody
said that um all right so
let's go one more video that we've got
here uh this is the white house press
secretary
jenn pasake this girl is constantly
circling back to people about things she
has no idea what she's doing up there
kaylee has
her successor is just a disaster kaylee
good for you
you're done you're done good um she
chimed in jen pasaki chimed in about the
gamergate thing and what the government
should maybe do go ahead
thanks i want to ask you about gamestop
um some
lawmakers have proposed legislative
reforms like
restrictions on short selling and uh
financial
transactions tax that the latter of
which uh president obama supported
during the 2020 campaign so i want to
ask you now if the white house
would support actions like those to
address the situation
well as we've noted in here several
times before but i just want to
reiterate obviously this is under the
purview of the sec in terms of
their review and monitoring but this is
uh there is an important set of policy
issues
that have been raised as a result of
market volatility in recent days and
we think congressional attention to
these issues is appropriate and would
welcome working with congress
moving forward as we dig into these
further policy issues but
uh i don't have anything further to
predict for you other than
um we certainly uh welcome the
opportunity to work with members who
have proposed ideas there's been any
direct engagement with those members so
far and what they proposed
uh i don't have anything to read out for
you on that front obviously we're
engaged
at a variety of levels every day with a
range of offices on
a number of issues um so but i don't
have anything more for you on that
there's a lot of interesting stuff there
i mean beyond the fact that look if
you're a white house press secretary
you know you're just sort of laundering
information to the people that's what
they all have to do kaylee mcinerney who
i
really thought was extremely good like
at the end of the day like that's what
they do
they're the pr people for the
administration there was something
interesting there because
she said they'd look into restrictions
on short selling now restrictions on
short selling the hedge fund guys have
been doing this forever they have been
profiting off the destruction of
companies forever
now that the people right now that you
and me and anyone else that wants to get
in on the game has figured out a
loophole
now they're going to look into it so now
the government's going to get involved
and also a financial transactions tax
because there's nothing the government
can't figure out a way to tax
well if you're just a little guy in on
the game and suddenly every time you
make a transaction there's a tax
well that's going to probably preclude
you from doing more
in a way when it wouldn't preclude the
big guy from doing it so the more that
government gets involved and we're going
to look at it
and do all this stuff well government is
not very good
at anything but it's it's very clear
what the government is going to do here
mark my words and elizabeth warren is
all about it because
she pretended she was for the people but
she's really for power
because when you're a progressive you
like centralized power so it doesn't
matter what the issue is
your answer is always oh we can fix it
if you just give us enough power
and what in essence she's saying there
is oh we're going to look at it it's up
to the sec we control the sec we are the
government
and we're going to figure out a way so
that this sort of thing
doesn't happen anymore we can't have the
people
figuring out a way to beat the big guys
uh and by the way guys
while all of this may be depressing at
some level like that now we're going to
see the system come down again
and attack the people very much in a
sort of coordinated way that the system
can say
take out the president of the united
states and make sure he can't listen to
music on spotify
um the the the silver lining to all of
this of course
is that in all of this chaos you know
what what it does it creates
fertile ground for building right
uh as you know it's what i'm doing with
locals.com there's a lot of other
interesting things happen
they can't break the human spirit and
they can't
quelch the human mind and human
ingenuity they can make it really
freaking difficult for us
but i am a firm believer that the more
they do that the more they take that
coal and crush it
that there will be a diamond there and
we got to make sure we're the ones
that are are cashing in on the diamonds
that we're the ones that are building
the diamonds actually
um because this is what the system does
it just it just is
um oh all right we've got one more story
here i'm a little behind it we've got a
lot going on
uh brian stelter you know this potato
shaped guy that's on
cnn he hosts a show called reliable
sources
which uh is the most ironically named
show in the history of television if it
was called unreliable sources then it
would
fit the network and be much more suited
to his very small skill set
he did a segment on how fox news
is scaring people let's take a look
dishonest cries of censorship are
filling
fox's airwaves with charges that these
guys right here
are being suppressed the word
censorship's been invoked almost 400
times
on fox this month alone and more than
300 times on newsmax
but reducing a liar's reach is not the
same as censoring freedom of speech
freedom of speech is different than
freedom of reach
and algorithmic reach is part of the
problem
if fox is going to keep transitioning
into the 24 7 tucker channel
then maybe it belongs next to sci-fi on
your channel lineup not msnbc
these need to be nuanced conversations
not edicts not orders
this is complicated but harm reduction
is
possible harm reduction is possible by
adding more news and less opinion to the
content
go with me on this for just a second
what what do you think might be
happening here do you think
perhaps that this isn't about brian
stelter wanting you to get a plethora of
information
or hear different points of view or
really care about what's true or what's
right
or do you think that maybe maybe brian
stelter's doing that there
segment because he doesn't like the
competition
you see guys uh cnn without fox news cnn
would have literally nothing to talk
about now i understand they're talking
about these dying dinosaurs as they're
in the tar pits and i'm just jumping
over them because our numbers at this
point are better than most
of what's going on on daytime cnn and
sometimes nighttime cnn
at some level it's sort of we got to
stop talking about it right like i think
maybe we're about
to get that to that inflection point
where talking about the mainstream media
will no longer serve a purpose
but we do still have to get the blue
pill people and by the way
i know how many of you and myself
included by the way
have family members have friends that
are still brainwashed
by this stuff but if you don't think
that fox news has a problem when it
comes to censorship that every time
someone says something on fox
that then you know media matters and
these dingbats at cnn and the rest of
them
try to get all their advertisers taken
away and not only get all their
advertisers taken away but then go
directly
to the advertisers right so the my
pillow guy mike lindell who i've had on
the show who's now banned from twitter
often what he would do is if there was a
boycott of tucker he would double down
on advertising make even more money fox
it would all work
for them well now they've taken out mike
lindell and from last i heard i think
his pillows
someone can you check on this and if i'm
mistaken if we can't do a live fact
check i'll check it tomorrow
but i think his pillows were even taken
out of kohl's and bed bath and beyond
now
so we have a sort of corporate fascism
happening at this very moment and cnn is
in many ways the driver of it
they want to make sure and msnbc wants
to make sure
that it's not just uh scary youtubers
yeah it was calls and bad bath okay
um that it's not just us scary youtubers
that are taken out but it will also be
fox and then
and then and then as emperor palpatine
said
and then we shall have peace
you see what these guys are doing guys
so just you know
keep your head out of the sand and uh
we're gonna have to navigate this stuff
together oh by the way uh part one of my
interview with andy no you guys andy no
and you you know
andy no uh he has been tracking antifa
from the beginning
and uh i think one of the most
interesting things about my conversation
with him
is that i've known this guy since he was
basically since he was a kid he was like
this young college journalist who kind
of
was was interested in this space and and
i've met him
several times over the years and he's
been tracking antifa from the beginning
he's been
subjected to violence from antivirus i'd
say he's as big of an expert
on what's going on uh with the violence
and the messaging and all of that so we
posted part one on our youtube channel
uh this morning the full episode is
already up ad free at
reubenreport.locals.com
uh oh and we're doing a uh spirituality
and religion panel
this friday guests tba but we've got
well just you know we're going to have
some christians catholics and jews
it'll be they're going to walk into a
bar we'll see what happens all right
thanks for watching everybody
more tomorrow have a great monday